two hostages including an American were
freed overnight in a rare prisoner swap
with the Taliban the men had been held
captive for more than three years Holly
Williams is following developments from
Istanbul Turkey hala what are what do we
know about this swap Ali good morning
well Kevin king from Pennsylvania was
the last known living American hostage
being held by the Taliban
he was released today along with an
Australian hostage Timothy weeks
both men were teachers at the American
University in Kabul when they were
kidnapped back in 2016 they appeared in
Taliban hostage videos pleading for
their release during their more than
three years in captivity in a statement
Kevin King's sister said it had been a
quote painful ordeal for the entire
family the Afghan government has
confirmed to CBS News this morning that
the two men were exchanged for three
senior members of the Taliban one of
them is enough Haqqani now he is a key
figure the son of the founder of the
Haqqani network that is a wing of the
Taliban notorious for its brutality and
it's suicide bombings the Taliban has
confirmed today that 10 members of the
Afghan state security forces were also
released as part of this prisoner swap
this prisoner exchange is apparently an
attempt to restart peace talks with the
Taliban and end
Afghanistan's 18 year long war the US
was close to an agreement with the
Taliban back in September but those
negotiations broke down Tony
Holly Williams for us Holly thank you
very much